This episode is brought to you by curiosity stream,
a subscription streaming service that offers over 2000 documentaries and
non-fiction titles unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month in 30 days
for free. If you sign up using the code biographics, there is a link below,
more on them in a bit
He's bloody.
Mary May simply evoke images of a stick of celery in a tall glass or
memories of your last brunch.
But the origin of the term comes of course from queen Mary,
the first of England, daughter of Henry, the eighth,
who led of Ireland's Catholic counter reformation against Protestantism.
But is that all there is to know about Mary Tudor?
Well stick with us today and we'll learn about Mary's unhappy upbringing
and her troubled reign play.
You get to buy personal and political disappointments.
Princess.
It was the first surviving child or King Henry,
the eighth of England's and Catherine queen of arrogant.
When Mary came into the world on February the 18th, 15, 16,
her father welcomes her as the greatest Parlin in the kingdom.
As proud as Henry might have been,
he rarely showed her affection to his daughter.
The King was more interested in using Mary as a diplomatic porn and the complex
game of alliances that had engulfed England France and the Holy Roman empire.
When Mary was just two years old,
she was betrothed to the doleful or Prince of France Francis. The third,
this wedding arrangements among two infants was all kinds of inappropriate,
and it was intended to secure an Alliance between England and France.
Four years later,
diplomatic relations between the two kingdom soured and the cringe factor just
escalated.
The six-year-old Mary was now offered in marriage to her mother's cousin,
the Holy Roman emperor, Charles, the fifth, who was aged 22.
The marriage never took place,
but mother Catherine wanted to ensure that Mary would be raised as a proper
princess worthy of an emperor. Mary was tutored by a Spanish Tuto,
one new Eve S who outlines our curriculum in the treaters called the
education of a Christian woman. According to Viv,
as young girls should be prepared for a life of humility, self sacrifice,
and to BDO once in the company of virtuous women,
men on the other hand should be avoided.
Girls should also restrain the fire of their youth.
It is preferable that they learn instead to weave and spin,
which includes a love of sober sadness. In other words, Catherine,
and Viva's raising marriage. You become a rather submissive young lady,
devoid of spirit and initiative,
but Mary had another role model in our household,
albeit one who dedicated her little attention, Henry the eighth from him,
Mary inherited a love of writing and hunting and to talent for playing the loose
and dancing. The King started to take notice of these, not so dainty traits.
So in the summer of 1525, he sent the nine year old lady married,
a Ludlow castle, and the Welsh marches.
This relocation carried a great symbolic value by presiding over that court,
Mary effectively acted as princess of Wales making her a prospect to inherit the
throne. Mary stayed in Ludlow in Seoul just after her 11th birthday.
When threats of a Welsh rebellion made it safer for her to leave for London.
When she returns, Mary was masked by a very tense situation.
Henry had informed queen Catherine that he intended to divorce,
that he was having a relationship with Ann Berlin, Mary stock,
by how grieving mother trying to console her through that difficult period from
1527 to 1533.
Now I won't go into all of the details of the annulments of Henry and
Catherine's marriage,
but one of the best known consequences of this was the schism of the church of
England from Catholicism 10 years after the beginning of the reformation major
European court adhere to Protestantism from Mary's perspective,
the schism from the church of Rome had deep personal connections.
Catholicism was her religion, as well as a mother's Protestantism.
The reformation represented the faith of Catherine's rival and Berlin,
which Henry had opportunistically embraced in July of 1533,
the 17 year old Mary was informed that her parents' marriage had been pronounced
invalid unless Henry and Nan were now man and wife never.
He was also told that she could no longer communicate with her mother and things
went from bad to worse after the 7th of September, 1533,
that is when Anne gave birth to princess Elizabeth. The future queen of England,
Mary was stripped of her total of princess and or to discern as a maid of honor
to Elizabeth.
The teenage Mary was moved to a new residence Hatfield house book off to a
health system.
She had been removed from her mother runs from her beloved lady in waiting
Margaret pole.
She had also been assigned to the worst lodgings in Hatfield and was routinely
humiliated by members of Elisabeth's households.
Chief among them was lady Shelton. The aunt of Anne Boleyn,
any other Cinderella would have accepted how fate is an errand girl,
well staging musical routines with a bunch of mice,
but Mary fought back with quiet dignity.
She always refused to address Elizabeth as princess and faint deafness.
If somebody addressed her as lady Mary, rather than princess Mary lady Shelton,
retaliated by confiscating her clothes and jewelry,
or even by abusing both verbally and physically,
if King Henry came around to visit Elizabeth,
the lady Shelton ensured that Mary was locked up,
preventing her from seeing how thought that Mary continued with her quiet
rebellion.
She learned how to exchange secret messages with a mother with the help of loyal
servants. Mary could also count on another ally, the Envoy of Charles,
the fifth to London, Spanish ambassador Eustis to poise.
Two boys became a good friend and made several attempts to intervene on her
behalf at court alas, they were all unsuccessful in 1534,
the English parliament ratified the act of supremacy,
which made the schism from Rome official and recognized. Henry.
The eighth was head of the church of England.
Mary was supposed to take a note recognizing him as such,
but she refused accepting the act of supremacy means admitting that Henry and
Catherine's marriage was illegal. Rejecting such an oath was equal to treason,
punishable by death, but Henry showing mercy,
let his daughter live at the beginning of February,
1535 just before her 19th birthday, Mary fell ill.
She had been suffering for some time from stomach pains, headaches,
and depression. But on that occasion,
her symptoms were worse than ever somebody at court, even suspected poisoning.
Henry had the good idea of sending her away from Hatfield to recover at the
Royal palace in Greenwich and recover.
She did albeit very slowly but barely one year later,
Mary received yet another devastating blow.
They Dee Shelton without tax or petty announced. This is on the 12th of January,
1536, Catherine of Aragon, uh, died.
[Inaudible].
What I'm going to improve. When King George,
the AIDS grew tired of his new wife or may the 19th, 1536 and Berlin's graceful.
Neck was struck by the execution, a risk, the tower of London.
She had been executed on trumped up charges of infidelity incest with her own
brother runs conspiracy to kill the King.
These accusations had been concocted by the King and his minister,
Thomas Cromwell.
There were many reasons behind the execution and it fails to give birth to a
male heir or an opposed in Alliance with the Holy Roman empire favoring,
the French or the King simply wanted to remarry.
What's massive for Mary is that Henry's new wife.
Jane Seymour had every intention to build a good relationship with that.
In the summer of 1536,
Mary was summoned to decor to meet her father for the first time in five years
at the time she was 20 years old and Henry had lost her as a troubled teenager.
He was now impressed by an intelligent,
confident woman who had survived years of abuse and neglect with dignity during
Christmas 1536,
the lady Mary was formally welcomed back at court for it to happen.
She was eventually forced to sign a document recognizing Catherine and Henry's
marriage is unlawful. Nonetheless, thanks to the family.
Unity created by queen Jane. Mary enjoyed a newfound happiness,
but the days of our benefactor, when numbered, because on October the 12th,
1537,
Jane fulfilled Henry's most persistent wish by giving birth to a son. Edward,
finally, this was the male ad that everyone was hoping for. Except of course,
for Mary ambitious and intelligent,
she knew her best path to the throne would not involve male as older
or younger. The birth of the Prince had another consequence.
Jenn was confined to bed with a bout of pure Aperol fever,
a fever caused by uterine infection, following childbirth.
She died 12 days later on the 24th of October King Henry was stricken with heavy
grief. He dealt with it in an emotionally mature way.
He left England's all together to pursue diplomatic missions.
Nary remains a court further blossoming into a well-liked member of the Royal
household.
She was a pious young women attending mass everyday and offering donations to
impoverish members of the clergy, but she also enjoyed hunting,
playing cards and attending shows with jesters foreign ambassadors,
Dalton to take note of the young lady admiring her intelligence nature and good
looks. She would have made a perfect bride for some foreign Prince. Well,
in theory in practice, her position was ambiguous.
Mary was formerly an illegitimate child. I mean,
remember that document that she was forced to sign moreover,
a potential future groom of Mary's good lay claims to the throne,
threatening the legitimate heir Prince Edward for this reason,
King Henry kept several suitors at Bay,
but of course he didn't have any problems with his ongoing nuptials.
In January of 1540.
He married down of plebes before quickly swiping left and tying the knot with
Catherine Howard. Catherine's date of birth is uncertain, but she was for sure,
younger than her stepdaughter. Mary,
initially the past Mary did not get along with dad's latest trophy wife,
but just as the two young ladies were becoming friends,
Henry received a letter from the Archbishop of Canterbury Thomas Crowner.
It accused Catherine of past and present sexual liaisons.
Henry announced a treason and had Catherine executed on February the 13th,
1542 following year Henry married for the sixth time with Catherine Paul,
like Jean Zemo before her was able to recreate some degree of family unity.
Mary enjoyed some quite happy time playing with Elizabeth and Edward.
She had now grown fond of a much younger half siblings,
but there was a growing cloud over their future. This Henry,
the eighth's grew older. I mean, what would happen after the death of the King,
but just before we get into what will happen,
let me tell you about today's sponsor.
CuriosityStream CuriosityStream is a subscription streaming service that offers
over 2000 documentaries and non-fiction titles from some of the world's best
filmmakers, including exclusive originals. Now, if you're enjoying this video,
then you're bound to find loads of stuff on their platform that you will love.
They got plenty of stuff about English history, including a great documentary,
by the way that reconstructs the life of William,
the conqueror it's called William the conqueror. And if you search for that,
you will find it. And that's just one example.
There's really so much stuff on curiosity stream that you are never going to run
out of interesting things to watch it's available on many platforms, web app,
Roku, Android, X-Box one. If you've got a screen,
you're probably going to be able to watch it on that screen.
Get unlimited access starting at just two 99 a month. And for you guys,
the first 30 days are completely free. If you sign up at curiosity,
stream.com forward slash biographics and use the promo code biographics during
the signup process, that's a great way to support the show.
Let's get back to the video.
Henry.
And on January the 28th, 1547,
his son was crowned as King Edward the sixth at nine years of age,
Mary withdrew to East Anglia, where she held her sort of parallel court,
which always included a Catholic priest reciting mass four times a day as King
Edward and his court continued the path to Protestantism.
Mary began to believe that her destiny was to keep the Catholic faith alive in
England. This conviction was reinforced by the ambassadors of Charles the fifth,
who had every interest in maintaining influence over her cousin and 1549.
The act of uniformity, outlawed Catholic mass,
replacing edge with services from the book of common prayer.
Mary would not comply with the act as she wrote to Charles,
the Fest in life or death. I will not forsake the Catholic religion,
even if compelled there too, by threats or violence,
a personal champion was intimidated on orders of Edward Seymour.
The Duke of Somerset.
This gentlemen was the uncle and Lord protector to the young King.
Edward eventually Seymour proved to be quite lenient,
allowing Mary to celebrate the Catholic rights privately,
but CMOs tenure as Lord protector was short-lived.
And his success of John Dudley,
Duke of Northumberland was openly hostile to Mary and Catholicism.
He defined a as the conduit by which the wraps of room or might creep into the
strongholds Dudley and even King Edward issued intimidations to Mary,
that she stopped celebrating mass, but she defiantly persisted.
This religious tug of war continued until February, 1553.
When Mary started hearing rumors about the King's ill health,
the 15 year old Edward,
the sixth was in fact suffering from severe tuberculosis and he was
deteriorating quickly.
This was the beginning of a deal of wits between Mary and John Dudley with the
prize being the throne of England,
Mary considered herself to be the rifle out of the crown while Dudley was ready
to sponsor another candidates in order to prevent a Catholic from becoming
queen. This was Dudley's daughter-in-law lady Jane grey,
who happened to also be the great granddaughter of the first two to King Henry
the seventh at the beginning of July, 1553,
Mary was in her Hartford sheer residence.
When she received a summons to Greenwich palace to sit by her dying.
Rather Mary feared this to be a trap from Dudley and she added a Norfolk instead
East of London, when she reached a court in Kenning hall on July the ninth,
she learns that ed would have died three days prior,
but the worst piece of news was that Dudley son was heading to Norfolk to
capture her Mary acted quickly and decisively.
She pronounced a self rightful queen of England's before her household and sent
a message to Dudley,
ordering him to accept our Rose Monarch Mary's message received Dudley.
When he was hosting a banquet for queen Jane grey,
which must have been all kinds of awkward Dudley had reassured queen and Jane
Nancy's, his allies that Mary would be easily tamed and controls,
but Mary would not yield.
And she started to amass an army of supporters recruited from the gentlemen and
peasants of East Anglia. Dudley had not been idle,
either sending an army and the fleet to confront Mary,
but the old were quickly turning against him by the 16th of July Mary's army
numbered,
about 30,000 and Dudley's fleet had switched sides on the 18th.
John Dudley yielded to his new queen and on August the third, 1553,
Mary Tudor Rhodes triumphantly into London proclaimed as the new queen of
England. She succeeded the unlucky lady, Jane grey queen of night and day.
England's welcome.
Mary, as a rightful heir to the throne,
she was first and foremost and adults and intelligent women heavily contrasted
against the previous boy King, but nobody knew what to,
from a single queen as Monarch,
the only precedents have been queen Matilda in the 12th century,
reign remembered as a chaotic time, but Mary got off to a good start,
making an impression as a virtuous conscientious and kind sovereign. Sure.
She had Dudley's head chopped off even after he had recanted his Protestant
faith,
but Mary was very lenient toward Dudley's allies and especially lady Jane grey,
who received a short sentence to be served at the tower of London.
The new queen gave proof of her great tolerances.
She had no intention to compel or constrain other men's consciouses straight
off the bat. Mary launched a series of much needed reforms.
English finances were in dark condition after years of malpractice endorsed by
Dudley Edward,
the sixth and Henry the eighth Mary's predecessors have taken to debasing the
coin at Joel lower in the proportion of golden silver and English circulation.
This debasement increased cashflow in the economy,
but eventually curbed foreign trade. What was the point of trading with England?
The pound was becoming worthless. Mary revalued, the currency.
And as while she initially intended to curb public spending,
she understood the necessity of investing in the military.
She expanded the Navy and incentivized exploration in the new world's a
long-term program whose rewards would be reaped by her successes,
but let's stay in the presence with the crown firmly on her head.
The Queen's counselors and subjects were busy with another question was Mary
intending to marry. And if so, when,
and to whom Mary had the same question in mind and sought the advice of Charles
the fifth, no surprise. The Habsburg emperor chose his only son,
Phillip Phillip had a reputation for being kind of dull, but on the plus side,
he was dignified serious 11 years younger than Mary and fantastically rich upon
the death of his father.
He would contribute to two pieces of prime real estate to a potential role in
marriage. The Netherlands and Spain.
This is to say that a union between Mary and Phillip would have brought together
two great powers. However,
Mary's counselors realized that England would have been the junior partner in
such an Alliance and England would likely become just another Habsburg dominion.
The Protestants within England's were also worried about the potential influence
of Spanish Catholic clergy, but Mary had made up her mind.
She would marry Philip whom she had seen only once in a portrait by Titian on
November the eighth, 1553. She announced her intentions, Mary Phillip,
and in January of 1554, she concluded a marriage treaty with Charles the fifth.
The news was badly received by a group of conspiring.
No woman led by sir Thomas White, the plot also involved Henry Gray,
father of lady Jane.
The plan called for four separate armies to March into London,
seize the court and replace Mary with a half sister Elizabeth sat to marry an
English nobleman the plan, however,
reached the ears of the Spanish ambassador who notified Mary's main advisor,
Lord chancellor, Stephen garden at the rebel Alliance of nobleman melted away.
But Thomas Wyatt did not back down on January the 26th, 1554.
Washington does small army occupied the Kentish town of Rochester issuing a
proclamation against the queen.
Mary sent two contingents to suppress the uprising,
but most of those soldiers swapped sides and joined Wyatt in less than a week.
He had rallied 4,000 men at his command ready to March on London.
Mary's counselors advised at a fleet,
but the queen would not have it on February.
The first she delivered a rousing speech to Londoners rallying their support two
days a day.
So why it's army arrived at the tower of London expecting to find little
resistance? They were solely wrong.
They found that Mary supporters blocked all bridges and we're in control of the
artillery atop the tower after a failed attempt to outmaneuver the defense's
watt surrender. It is easy to guess. The face of Thomas Weiss,
he ends 90 of his co-conspirators were tried and executed that bodies were left
to rot in the open as a warning against future rebellions.
The aftermath of the rebellion did not spare two ladies who may have posed a
threat to queen Mary. The first was our half sister, lady Elizabeth,
who had been approached by watt and friends to join their uprising.
But during a hearing with Mary's counselors,
Elizabeth managed to distance herself from the plot.
Mary realized that Elizabeth May still become a rallying figure for Protestant
schemes. And so she put her under house arrest for one year.
The second lady was the former queen Jane Gray,
and she did not get away so easily.
Her father Henry has been one of the rebels and she still carried legitimate
claims to the throne on February the 12th, 1554,
lady Jane grey was beheaded at the tower of London with the anti Spanish.
And anti-Catholic conspirators out of the way.
Mary was free to marry Prince Phillip,
albeit with some clauses out into the marriage treaty,
which became the sort of ultimate prenup.
And now stipulated that Phillip would be King of England only for the duration
of the marriage. And he would be unable to issue any proclamations or treaties.
He could also not appoint any foreigners to the English council and he could not
demanding England to support Spain in acts of war on July, the 25th, 1554,
the marriage of Mary and Phillip of England and Spain finally took place.
It seems that from the start, the union was not a happy one.
Phillip complains about the old age of Mary and Zack.
Courtney has described her as not at all beautiful small and rather flabby and
has no eyebrows for the showed little affection for his bride,
avoiding her most of the time. And yet in October of 1554,
Mary announced a pregnancy in April of 1555. The queen moved to Hampton court,
visibly pregnant and preparing for birth bumps the days and the weeks passed.
And nothing happens.
Members of Mary's household began noticing that belly was becoming flatter.
Again, eventually Mary and a doctors had to admit the truth.
They'd all been mistaken and the queen had never actually been pregnant.
So how was this possible after all she had displayed all the signs of pregnancy,
including the ceasing of a periods,
as well as swollen stomach and a discharge of milk.
It may be that Mary self from amenorrhea rare condition,
which causes painful and irregular periods and swelling of the abdomen and the
breasts of the hypotheses include a disorder of the pituitary glands,
uterine cancer, or even a Phantom pregnancy,
a deep rooted belief of expecting a child which generated psychosomatic
symptoms,
whatever the underlying cause by August all symptoms had subsided and Mary left
Hampton court as quietly as possible.
[Inaudible].
While Mary was coping with her apparent pregnancy,
one of our most trusted counselors was harder work on religious matters.
This was the new Archbishop of Canterbury carves and old original poles.
Son of Mary's format lady in waiting Cosmo poll oversaw Mary's counter
reformation, which culminated on November the 25th, 1554 on that date,
parliament repealed Henry the eighth act of supremacy and effectively reinstated
the Catholic faith in England. Three weeks later, Poland,
the parliament revived the medieval Harrison rules.
These grounds into the bishops,
the right to identify heresy suspects and the mover to secular authorities for
trial torture.
And it's very often execution by burning at the stake with the legal framework
in place.
Mary urged the authorities to be diligence in seeking out heresy and punishing
it with death. The first executions took place in February of 50 55.
Initially the flames consumed the bodies of Protestant clergyman,
such as John Hooper, Bishop of Gloucester,
the execution as a place to bag of gunpowder around his neck to accelerate
combustion as bad as it sounds. This was an active, messy,
but the gunpowder failed to ignite and the Bishop's agony lost into 45 minutes.
More high ranking clergymen followed Hooper's fate,
including Archbishop Thomas cram,
that he had led the Protestant reformation under Edward the sixth,
but had later denied his beliefs.
When Mary had ascended to the throne on the day of his execution, crammed up,
plunged his hand into the flames, his self punishment for his Audi recantation.
Besides these high-profile martyrs, most victims were commoners,
poor traders and laborers.
Some of them had been reported as heretic simply for not being able to recite
the launch prep. In one particularly horrific execution,
a pregnant woman was tied to the stake as their body was consumed by flames.
She gave birth to a child who was tossed to onto the raging fire.
So what happens in Mary? She started a rain as a fair and compassionate ruler.
She had executed Dudley white and just acolytes. Sure,
but that was the standard punishment for honey treason.
It has been argued that Mary believed she was fulfilling a destiny by restoring
England to the true faith, to save her subjects from the eternal flames of hell.
She believed it was an acceptable price to pay.
If some of them died at the stake,
the Marion persecutions caused the death of about 300 English subjects.
Since eventually,
while they back font Mary's blood test cause many law subjects to turn away from
Aaron Catholicism, by the end of 50 and 55,
Mary realized that her actions that only succeeded in expanding the cohorts of
her enemies, how has it been by the way was no longer by our side,
after the revelation of a false pregnancy,
he had relocated to the Netherlands where he enjoyed a life of jousting and
womanizing in awesome. 1556.
The queen found out that Phillip would be returning and she was delighted,
but Phillip's return was not for the sake of a family reunion.
The man even brought his mistress to London.
I'll know Phillip was now King of Spain and was planning a war with France and
needed England support King Phillip arrived in March of 1557 and married,
anxious to please her husband succumbs to his pressure.
Despite the council's protests.
She promised English support for his war with France Phillip's campaign in
France was short and successful in August. He captured San Quinn's intaking,
many French Aras to Kratz as hostages.
Phillip scored other minor victories until French King Henry the second Zoot for
peace.
And I'll tell you the 1557 Phillip left France and disbanded his Anglo Spanish
forces, but Henry was already plotting revenge.
This targets was Kalai jewel of the English crown on French lands in
December the French attacks approaching over the frozen Marsha's Henry soldiers
laid siege. The city Mary responded by dispatching a fleet from Dover,
but the ships arrived too late by the 13th of January, 1558,
French artillery had breached the walls of Carly and the city had fallen.
Guinean ham were conquered by Henry.
Mary had lost all of England's holdings in France,
lost foothold on the continent. The fall of KLA was a devastating blow for Mary,
but it was somewhat softened by the realization that she was pregnant.
She waited until December of 1558 to notify Philip reassuring him that this time
it was for real, except, but it wasn't. The baby was due in March, but by may,
no child had been born.
It appeared that Mary's distended belly was the sign of a fatal case of dropsy.
The accumulation of fluid under the skin,
which may lead to kidney failure in June. The queen became feverish by August.
Her doctors predicted that death was inevitable. Queen Mary to,
to finally died on the morning of November, the 17th,
1558 at the age of 42 shortly before her death,
she made the prediction that those who opened our body would find the words
Phillip and Kalay carved onto our heart. During her short five-year reign,
Mary Tudor was beset with personal and political disappointments.
Well summarized by the two words, supposedly inscribed on our heart.
She did initiate some important reforms,
which set the stage for a stronger England to become a sea power,
the skill bend resilience she displayed before becoming queen a remarkable.
It is undeniable. Nonetheless,
that the persecutions Mary instigated are one of the darkest pages in English
history.
Mary is remembered for an unjust and unjustified repression of religious
expression, which eventually turned against us yet.
A certain queen who came after her had 640 people executed
190 of them for religious reasons.
But we remember her as Gloriana and just as increased SETA King,
who came before her ordered 2000 prisoners beheaded in the Holy land,
simply because he grew impatient with negotiations,
but we remember him as lawn hos.
I'm not suggesting that Mary's reign should never be remembered as bloody,
but is it fair to single her out as such?
Or would it be fair to reassess our legacy?
I'm looking forward to hearing your verdicts in the comments and as usual,
thank you for watching. Please do check it off.
Fantastic sponsor curiosity stream, and I'll see you next time.